the war in Ukraine might not be over
anytime soon America's spy Chief Avril
Haynes has offered a grim outlook on the
possible trajectory of Vladimir Putin's
Invasion she says the conflict could
escalate even further and become even
more unpredictable and predicting Putin
has never been easy but Hayes believes
the Russian president has wore aims
extending far beyond the Eastern Don
bass region and that he still has his
sights set on regime change in order to
achieve these aims Mr Putin would have
to resort to more Extreme Measures
taking charge of industrial output
ordering full military mobilization
inside Russia and employing even more
brutality on the battlefield here's
Avril Haynes the Director of National
Intelligence
War we assess President Putin is
preparing for a prolonged conflict in
Ukraine during which he still intends to
achieve goals beyond the dambas we
assess the Putin's strategic goals have
probably not changed suggesting he
regards the decision in late March to
refocus Russian forces on the donbass is
only a temporary shift to regain the
initiative after the Russian military's
failure to capture Kiev
and while it was because of concerns of
the future course of the war in Ukraine
that British prime minister Boris
Johnson traveled to Sweden and Finland
today there he signed agreements to come
to their defense in the event of an
attack the possible aggressor was not
named but the agreements were clearly
aimed at deterring Russian President
Vladimir Putin from aggressive action
we are taking another step to
strengthening our bilateral defense and
security cooperation at the Strategic
level and I'm very happy that you have
come here today for the signing of our
bilateral political Declaration of
solidarity the war in Ukraine is forcing
us all to make difficult decisions
but Sovereign Nations must be free to
make those decisions without fear or
influence or threat of retaliation and
if either country should suffer a
disaster or an attack the United Kingdom
and Sweden will assist each other in a
variety of ways it's worth emphasizing
that if Sweden were attacked and looked
to us for help and support then we would
provide it
my first guest is Alexander Cara a
Ukrainian Diplomat foreign policy and
security expert who was also an advisor
to the Minister of Defense in Ukraine he
joins me tonight from Kiev a very warm
welcome to the day sir uh we just saw
good to have you with us we just saw
their Sweden and the UK signing a mutual
defense pact Finland agreed a similar
defense deal both of these two nations
may now be fast-tracked into NATO do you
think Ukraine's bid to join the alliance
will happen anytime soon
well certainly it's not going to happen
soon but I am optimistic about the uh
the possibility of Ukraine to join in
NATO and actually shoot uh Finland and
Sweden join NATO and there would be no
let's say harsh reaction from Moscow it
would destroy the whole propaganda
Narrative of Russia that they are
fearful of the NATO advancement towards
their borders for as a primary reason
why they are fighting against Ukraine so
uh I believe it's a wise decision for
Finland and Sweden to be protected under
the
umbrella of NATO and suddenly we wanted
to have such an umbrella back into 2008
unfortunately for the position of
Germany and France we were blocked and
we now in Dire Straits firstly Georgia
in 2008 when Russia Unleashed its Force
against this Republic and then since
2014 uh Ukraine so certainly I would
love to see Ukraine with it was in NATO
and I believe we will have I will season
this opportunity in future
full metal ship your country has
arguably military and financial backing
from your Western allies could Kiev
potentially accept some sort of
strategic neutrality aligned with them
but forever outside the defense pact if
that is what Moscow wants to end this
bloody war
uh well I believe that the contribution
of Estonia one third of its defense
budget to Ukraine's Ukrainian defense
proves that those countries or the
baltics Poland Romania and some others
will wise enough to join NATO because it
will protected them from the same faith
that we are facing with Russia so that's
why I see no reason for Ukraine to give
up on our NATO membership aspiration
because we don't have any other
possibility to preserve a sovereignty a
territorial integrity and Independence
Russia attacked us when we were
non-blake non-block country in back in
2014 and it shifted the public opinion
towards the NATO membership decisively
from something like 45 percent to 60 and
80 later on so I see no other
possibility of Ukraine to secure its
future or either with the NATO or with
special partnership people with United
States and some other countries that
could provide us the guarantees no less
than article 5.
now
you're a diplomat and there has been
some decidedly undiplomatic language
between Berlin and Kiev in recent weeks
and some of it was born out of Germany's
past policies to forge closer ties with
Russia our Washington Nibiru Chief Ines
Paul spoke to Christopher Hoskin who was
the foreign policy advisor to Chancellor
Angela Merkel I want to play a clip for
you to listen to and then get your
reaction if I may
basically I think the the idea that we
had since the end of the second world
war after
um you know in the name of Germany 27
million Soviets were killed I think for
us to try and get into a better
relationship with um with Russia to
build Bridges I think was the right
right policy we just have to realize
that Russia Today is ready to destroy
all these bridges that we have been
trying to build
uh Mr Cara the Christian Christian
hostgun rather they're defending
Germany's policy of change through trade
is he defending the indefensible in your
opinion
oh yes sure uh because uh first of all
uh he for some reason uh Germany feel
guilty if our Jews being killed during
the second world war and Russians rather
than below Russians and ukrainians who
are actually the the bigger number than
Russians were killed by the Nazi uh
during the second world war and the
whole war was uh on our territory not on
the Russian territory so that's why this
uh the the whole idea that there is a
special guilt towards Russia and
building all those bridges is something
of special interest and actually I would
uh I would quote the leader of this
social Democrats recently he announced
that his party is changing or revising
us politic towards Russia in in other
countries and he admitted the wrong
doing of such a thing like over
estimating Russian importance and
underestimating the concerns of the
Central and Eastern European countries
so I believe this is right away how to
reassess the mistakes of the consecrated
governments in Germany and a reading of
Russia in general and certainly this
ignorance of Germans towards the Central
and Eastern Europeans in their uh let's
say a feeling and understanding of
Russia much better than the the
so-called old Europeans so I believe we
can mend this uh we and possibly there
are some mistakes from Ukrainian side we
haven't been trying to make Germans feel
guilty for all those committed crimes so
during the second world war like Russia
has been doing and underlying its
importance uh in in defeating Nazi uh
but we we were doing it from this
absolutely different point of view
because we we've seen the Germany and
Germans realized those crimes and they
they change their self to completely and
actually it's a different case with
Russia what we have seen now this
aggressive work is Ukraine it's the the
roots of this is that communism was not
condemned like Nazism in during their
process and to this Russia Russian
ideology is based on imperialism and
communism uh band together even though
it's an incomparable things from from
the same mind so we we we would like to
see more changes in the thinking uh of
Germans uh with regard to Russia in with
regard to not just Ukraine but the whole
bunch of countries to the east of
Germany
all right to Alexander Cara Ukrainian
Diplomat foreign policy and security
expert thank you for your time
thank you for invitation